[Music]
ncis has stood head and shoulders above
most of its police procedural peers for
years thanks to its lovable cast of
eclectic characters and almost uncanny
longevity the cbs show has been running
since 2003 and the ongoing season 19
finds the series as strong as usual
however it's clear that the show's
arguably most massive change yet is on
the not too distant horizon and it's
been looking that way for a while for 18
years the stalwart leader of the titular
investigation team in ncis has been led
by leroy jethro gibbs played by mark
harmon who was the backbone of the show
throughout its first 18 seasons season
19 of ncis has revealed that new
developments along with 18 seasons of
hard-hitting investigations weighing
down on his broad shoulders have caused
gibbs to decide that he's done with his
ncis job and that he's planning to carve
a new life for himself in alaska it's an
understandable development for the
character for anyone who watched the
season 18 finale the episode showed
gibbs boarding a boat that wasn't
destined to last long as it sailed out
to sea it unexpectedly blew up
fortunately fans saw gibb's body not
long afterward with him soon swimming to
shore it let everyone know gibbs would
return for season 19 but it definitely
gave the impression he wasn't going to
be around much longer but what exactly
caused the character to decide so or
rather what prompted mark harmon to join
the many actors who have left ncis the
hollywood reporter states mark harmon's
exit from the show is a pretty final one
at least in his starring capacity after
all the star is only signed for a
limited amount of episodes for season 19
and gives gibbs decision to remain in
alaska pretty much removes him from the
fabric of the show for the foreseeable
future what's more the ongoing season
features some brand new star power in
the form of katrina law and rumored
harmon replacement gary cole harmon's
limited episode deal means that gibbs
has effectively left his active role in
the show behind but showrunner stephen d
binder is quick to note that the actor
will maintain a behind the scenes role
and there's always a chance for an
on-screen comeback as well binder stated
as an executive producer and dear friend
mark continues to be an integral part of
the fabric of the show our north star
has always been staying true to our
characters and that truth has always
guided the stories we tell and where
those characters go so regarding the
future of gibbs as longtime fans of the
show may have noticed over the years
never count leroy jethro gives out that
means viewers may not have shed their
last tears over gibbs just yet if we
were into betting we'd be willing to put
down money on mark harmon returning for
the series finale whenever that occurs
it's hard to say goodbye to a beloved tv
character especially one who's been on
the air for nearly two decades leroy
jethro gibb starred in hundreds of ncis
episodes and has earned a special place
in people's hearts the show just won't
be the same without him and fans have
already taken to social media to let
their thoughts known on the emotional
departure it's entirely possible his
final scene of fishing on a lake and the
great unknown will be the last time
audiences see gibbs but at least he
received the send-off he so richly
deserved fans were quick to chime in
with their thoughts one fan wrote i am
sad gibbs is leaving ncis i got to
respect and applaud mark harmon for his
performance through 18 years as gibbs
another fan noted i just learned mark
harmon is leaving ncis and i'm in
complete shock i grew up with ncis and
especially with agent leroy jethro gibbs
but he did his time and i'm really proud
he had such an amazing journey gibbs has
certainly come a long way ever since he
first graced people's screens on the
episode ice queen on jag he'd only
appear on one more jag episode before
spinning off into ncis where he's been
ever since harmon walked away when the
time was right just like the great gibbs
so famously said when the job is done
walk away
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you